we are US citizens but we're not able to
vote for the United States president a
third of our island is occupied by the
US military the United States could have
made Guam estate at any time it hasn't
in part one of the series I looked at
how Guam became a colony of the United
States in this part I want to look at
what it's really like to live in an
American territory and how some people
are envisioning a different relationship
between Guam and the US for tourists the
five populated US territories seem like
great places to take a tropical vacation
but the people who live there face
higher unemployment than the national
average and the worst poverty rates in
the country on Guam the poverty rate is
50% higher than the rest of the US the
military presence here is huge with
installations taking up 27% of the
islands land with all this in mind many
young people on Guam see the military as
an opportunity I joined because I felt
like I needed a foundation to start off
my career
Chad wants to work in the entertainment
industry but with limited options on
Guam the military seemed like a good
stepping stone to reach his dreams
why does enough today guys good morning
today is a brand new day
[Music]
I'm from Georgia a little village
village of Jonah and Guam this is one
house that we all grew up in in my
grandmother sounds like everyone from my
great-grandmother to my grandmother to
my mom I was like what am I gonna do and
my dad was telling me he was like you
should just join the airforce and I was
like really
the airforce I don't think I'm fit for
that or cut out for that and so when I
did decide to join what made me go
through it is my dad my brothers who
joined they if they did it then I could
do it being in the military is like
having an all-access pass to study work
cheaper prices and a chance to explore
the world life on base can feel like a
privilege compared to many neighborhoods
on the island you kind of just like get
tired of the same routine and get tired
of the same minimum wage pay and so
you're thinking like what can I do to
get better financial stability the only
answer to that like to me I think is the
military it's really a local Islander
thing it seems like it's beyond
patriotic you know it's engraved in our
blood you know it's a family traditional
thing I joined the military when I was
in high school my senior year and I was
18 years old
Guam actually has a higher military
enlistment rate than any state as many
as one in eight adults care of veterans
but that doesn't mean they have the same
rights as most US citizens
Ronni served two tours in Iraq and has
since created an organization to help
veterans recover from the trauma of war
in here we have right now we have hands
yeah we have a couple baby chicks and so
how did how did this help veterans who
come here it really takes your mind off
what you're going through what you
experienced on range well Rodney's proud
of his military service he wasn't happy
with how he was treated by Veterans
Affairs when he retired and returned to
Guam it's taken me 15 years to finally
get actual services for treatment
currently I fly to Hawaii to receive my
counseling through a psychologist when
you look at the appointment wait times
they've exceeded 30 days some as much as
eight months
summers a year and that's why betters
just give up on the VA to give up on the
system many veterans on Guam believes
that they're treated differently because
they're a territory there's only one
outpatient clinic on the island with two
doctors to serve thousands of veterans
and it's common for vets to take a
seven-hour flight to Hawaii for services
like specialized PTSD treatment
Rodney's tours in Iraq have taken a toll
he's experienced depression and survived
a suicide attempt to lose people in
battle to see that to pick up the body
parts of American soldiers being
diagnosed of PTSD traumatic brain
injuries spinal problems and stuff like
that not being able to vote for a
president is it's like a piece of me is
missing even though when I say I I see
it painfully
if qualms were estate it would have more
political power to get better resources
and have a say and who gets to be
President I know it's better for me and
my family and if I had a choice that
would be pushing for statehood
Rodney's taking the fight to the Supreme
Court he's joined a lawsuit that's
fighting to give the four million
Americans who live in the territories
the right to vote it's an uphill battle
I couldn't stop thinking that despite
Rodney and Chad service they still can't
vote for president I wanted to know what
the military thought about all this
what's the military's response to the
fact that so many people from Guam serve
in the US military but can't even vote
for their commander and she
I don't have a response for it that's a
question that has nothing to do with the
military does the military support
anything in terms of status quo while
becoming a state the DoD doesn't have an
opinion you know on the political status
of the island except to just be the best
neighbors that we can be quaaludes
anguilla Ksenia man monofin I'm going
against it a no-bid zoo well I wasn't
even doing esteem and even mocked Amagi
in Asperger's Annabella nest in a new
god it's always important to ask for
permission whenever you're entering a
place where there's artifacts or the
bones of of ancient tomorrow's not
everyone thinks statehood is the best
way forward maguet is part of the
independence movement that wants to
change guam's relationship with the
military he took us to the cultural site
right adn also known as late-- axon
which has caves with indigenous Chamorro
markings dating back generations you
come in here and you get reminded that
man a thousand years ago maybe somebody
there was a chore who is standing here
and it's like a message it's like hey
don't give up maguet in the independence
movement are fighting to preserve sites
like these but the military plans to
build a firing range right next door
it's part of a military buildup that
would move 5,000 additional Marines from
Okinawa Japan to Guam a lot of people
who have come to the Texan who sort of
walked down this trail who see the
medicinal plants here who go into the
caves for them they're like why would
you want to disrupt a place like this
the firing range will limit access for
locals who use this area regularly well
and it seems like even to this day
people are coming here to get plants for
healing to come in here to go for
fishing oh absolutely
this is why the firing range issue is so
contentious a lot of these culturally
significant areas are on bases as an
individual you can't say you know what I
would like to go and visit a sacred site
to my answer
because there is a fence there's a
there's a gate there's a passed
procedure just look at a map of Guam 212
square miles one-third of it military
facilities all of these things are tied
to us being a territory independent gwon
is trying to get people to think about
an alternative to Guam's current status
inspired by the strength of our
ancestors we educate and unify all who
call our island home to build a
sustainable and prosperous independent
future independence is is a way for us
to redefine ourselves and to really
return to who we were intended to be by
our ancestors the threat of a nuclear
attack from North Korea is in Guam's
recent memory but the independence
movement doesn't want to be caught in
the middle of US conflicts any longer it
became more urgent for me as a mother
because I often think well what do I
want my children to inherit there is no
choice this is my home man this is their
home man I would rather that they be
here and know who they are than anywhere
else
so this is the place that is their home
I want to make it safe I want to make it
reach its greatest potential for that
others argue that without the military
to defend it
Guam would be an easy target especially
when it comes to nuclear warfare there's
some people who are like they quote free
Guam I'm like free one for what
if you want so we can get bombed but
maguet says that independence doesn't
necessarily mean kicking the u.s. out
he says Guam could have a defense
agreement with the military the u.s.
would keep its basis here if they agreed
to defend the island in return over the
past 70 or 80 years but 80 different
countries moved from being colonies to
independent and in that time Guam kind
of remained stuck in the exact same
place what we have now with the
relationship between Guam in the United
States is the relationship between a
colony and a colonizer it's a
relationship that shouldn't exist
anymore just like most people would say
a relationship between a slave and a
master shouldn't exist anymore in 2017
the UN decolonization committee voted in
favor of a resolution calling for the
u.s. government to cooperate with guam's
right to self-determination to decide
whether it should be a state independent
or something else but that resolution is
non-binding guam's colonial past has
created a system of dependency on the US
militarily and economically but there's
a growing group of young people on Guam
who are looking to traditional Chamorro
culture to help change the future of
their Island
thank you for watching parts you keep
watching because in this next episode
we're going spearfishing there's an
amazing group of young people on Guam
who are embracing indigenous traditions
to create a more sustainable future I
really want you to meet them don't
forget to Like share and subscribe to
keep watching
untold America